vamos con nuestro primer invitado del
día se cumplen tres años de su salida de
la Unión Europea pero Reino Unido aún no
se ha beneficiado de esas promesas del
brexit en su economía el 31 de enero del
2020 del entonces Primer Ministro Boris
Johnson aseguró que el país finalmente
podría alcanzar su potencial y que
esperaba de que aumentara su confianza
cada mes que pasaba sin embargo en la
actualidad del país se esfuerza por ir a
la par de sus vecinos las encuestas de
opinión muestran que los ciudadanos que
lamentan abandonar la Unión Europea
superan cada vez más a los que aún
apoyan la salida vamos al análisis de
este tema con Oscar Guardiola él es
escritor y profesor de Bird Beck College
University de Londres Oscar gracias a
usted por estar con nosotros desde el
voto del brexit bajaron las inversiones
del país las empresas se lo piensan dos
veces para ver si vale la pena adaptarse
al nuevo sistema y poner su capital y su
entrenamiento en planta física en un
país que ya no tiene el respaldo de la
Unión Europea se puede revertir esa
tendencia
es posible que la tendencia ya se haya
revertido como lo decías muy bien Ángela
en efecto todas las
todos los las mediciones en este momento
nos dicen que cerca del 57 al 59% de los
británicos estaría a favor de regresar a
la Unión Europea solamente una cuarenta
y cinco a cuarenta y nueve por ciento
sigue insistiendo en que es necesario
estar fuera de la unión y a números aún
más grandes tienen Claro que brexit ha
sido un fracaso ahora bien la
posibilidad de un regreso a la Unión
Europea o por lo menos a la zona
económica al sistema de aduanas es
difícil por razones políticas en este
momento el gobierno conservador que se
encuentra en enormes dificultades
políticas económicas y por supuesto
electorales
preferiría Por supuesto que su opositor
el partido laborista
volviese insistir en la necesidad de
encontrarse dentro de la unión para
beneficiarse electoralmente eso hace
difícil que podamos ver en muy corto
plazo Un regreso de Gran Bretaña a la
unión pero pero claro uno se pregunta
cómo sería ese procedimiento y si es
algo realmente palpable ante los malos
resultados Por supuesto que ha vuelto la
discusión de entrar de nuevo al mercado
único y el alcalde de Londres lo puso
muy en claro y al decir que el brexit
era un fracaso pero le pregunto en
términos prácticos Es una posibilidad
porque sabemos cuánto puede tomar
solamente la aceptación de una
candidatura Para volver a estar en la
Unión Europea Cuántos años se toma esto
y Y pues también escuchamos hace tres
años las advertencias clarísimas de la
Unión Europea sobre una salida
Irreversible
de nuevo hay al menos dos dificultades
cruciales la primera tiene que ver con
la situación con la situación política y
económica interna a la que me referí
antes ninguno de los dos partidos parece
querer tocar el tema o lo hacen con
mucha cautela como lo expresó el miembro
del gabinete de oposición David en estos
días y de la otra Como bien sugieres
pues es difícil encontrar por qué
debería haber mayor interés por parte de
la Unión Europea para que Gran Bretaña
volviera volviese a unirse en este
momento la Unión Europea enfrenta otro
tipo de retos la guerra en Ucrania por
supuesto es uno de ellos y no existe
mayor interés si no existe razón para
que
hubiese interés en volver a entrar en
las negociaciones muy complicadas
una posible representantes británicos
además
digamos el tipo de
expresiones
hasta ofensivas casi insultantes por
parte de quienes estuvieron en la mesa
de negociación pues explican que haya
muy poca motivación por parte de la
Unión Europea para
enfrentar una posible reentrada de Gran
Bretaña de hecho hasta Alguien podría
argumentar que si alguien se ha
beneficiado con la salida Gran Bretaña
es la Unión Europea Gran Bretaña siempre
había sido un socio difícil por decirlo
menos mire sin embargo el gobierno
encabezado por el Primer Ministro
defiende que la nación está prosperando
con nuevas libertades Cuáles son esas
libertades o esas ventajas que defiende
da un Street al día de hoy
bueno la frase de Richi es una que hoy
es una muestra más de su enorme
debilidad política y muy escasa
credibilidad nadie entiende a qué
comunidades se refería cuando dijo esta
mañana que
las comunidades británicas habían sido
habían ganado poder tras el brexit
quizás se refiera a las comunidades de
más de derechas y de ultraderechas que
empiezan a ver con buenos ojos la
posibilidad de que Gran Bretaña tras
haberse separado de la Unión Europea
ahora se separe de la convención Europea
de Derechos Humanos sabemos que existe
un proyecto existe un proyecto que está
haciendo curso en el parlamento
el comité bipartidista del parlamento ya
le dijo al ministro dominicrap que lo
mejor que podía hacer con esa propuesta
que implicaría reducción considerable en
las protecciones de derechos humanos de
los ciudadanos británicos Es simplemente
tirarla al bote de la basura quizás sea
esas comunidades a las que se refiere
pero ninguna otra en verdad se ha
beneficiado Oscar Nos quedamos sin
tiempo muy rápidamente Le quiero
preguntar por el tema de este renovado
pedido de independencia de Escocia Cómo
podría desarrollarse esta discusión
la discusión va a ser difícil y va a
tardar tiempo habrá que esperar una el
tránsito de la demanda que va a ser que
prometió hacer el gobierno escocés en la
Corte Suprema Pero por supuesto el tema
es político y es la debilidad del
gobierno de Londres la que le permite a
Escocia Elevar el tono de voz en favor
de la Independencia y Bueno finalmente
sabemos que el país Reino Unido se vio
muy afectado por la pandemia y también
por el aumento de los precios desatado
por la Guerra de Ucrania pero este es un
escenario que vivieron todos los
gobiernos Reino Unido sin embargo es el
único miembro del g7 que no ha podido
volver a sus niveles prepandemia y que
contrario a sus colegas pues va a
presentar una reducción de su economía
en un 0,6% que nos dice esto de la
realidad del país tres años después
en efecto se trata del resultado por
supuesto de doce años de austeridad de
privatizaciones y de decisiones
económicas completamente ideológicas
pero lo que hace brexit ya es Claro que
al menos una disminución del cuatro por
ciento en la productividad británica
relativa a la que podría haber tenido si
continuase siendo miembro de la unión es
del caso así que brexit ha sido en
verdad
no solamente no beneficioso sino muy
perjudicial tanto para la economía como
para la política del Reino Unido